We're asked to compute 4,800,
or four thousand eight
hundred, divided by 80, and then
they want us to check our
answer, or they say
check your answer.
So I'll first do it just the
traditional long division way,
and then we'll think about if
there's maybe a faster way to
do this or if we can even
do it in our heads.
So let's just do it the
traditional way first. So we
have 80 and we want to
divide it into 4,800.
Four thousand eight hundred.
Or if we want to know the
terminology, 80 is the
divisor, 4,800 is the dividend,
and in the number
that we get, the number of times
80 goes into 4,800, we
could call that the quotient.
I always get confused when I
start using words like that,
so we just think of it as 80 is
being divided into 4,800.
Now, the first thing we say:
Well, does 80 go into 4?
No.
Does 80 go into 48?
No, it's bigger than 48.
Does 80 going into 480?
Well, that looks interesting.
Let's see, 6 times 8 is 48,
so 6 times 80 is 480.
We could do that right here.
80 times 6.
6 times 0 is 0.
6 times 8 is 48.
Or another way you could have
thought about it is 6 times 8
is 48, and we have this
extra 0 here, so you
add the 0 right there.
So 80 goes into 480 six times,
because we're only
considering the 480.
We put the 6 right in 480's one
spot, which is really the
tens place, but if you just
think about the 480, it's
right above the zero.
Now 6 times 80 is-- we already
saw-- 480, and then we can
subtract, and we get the
zero, and we bring
down another zero.
80 goes into 0 how many times?
Well, it goes into
it zero times.
0 times 80 is 0.
You subtract.
You get zeroes, and there's
nothing left to bring down, so
we're done.
4,800 divided by 80 is 60.
When the dividend is 4,800,
the divisor-- let me write
these words down.
This is divisor.
This is dividend.
Then our quotient is 60.
Now they want us to check our
answer, so we just have to
confirm that 60 times 80 is
4,800 so let's do that.
60 times 80-- now there's
two ways you can do it.
You could just literally say 6
times 8 is 48, and then it'll
have two zeroes here,
one, two.
That's 4,800.
Or we could do it by hand.
0 times 0 is 0.
0 times 6 is 0.
Then we'll put a zero
here because we're
now in the tens spot.
Put the zero here.
8 times 0 is 0.
8 times 6 is 48.
Add all of this up.
You get 4,800, so it works.
A faster way would just have
been to say 8 times 6 is 48,
and you have one, two zeroes
here, so one, two
zeroes right there.
Now, a quick way to think about
4,800 divided by 80 is
to divide both of these numbers
by 10 first. And just
to think about it this way, what
we're doing, this could
be written as 4,800/80.
Or this could be written as--
let me write it down here.
4,800/80 could be written as 480
times 10 over 8 times 10.
4,800 is just 480 times 10,
and 80 is just 8 times 10.
Now what happens here?
We could view this as being
equal to 480/8 times this 10
up here divided by this 10.
Now, what's 10 divided by 10?
What's any non-zero number
divided by itself?
Well, this is just
going to be 1.
10 goes into 10 one time,
so we're just left
with 480 over 8.
So essentially, you can
just knock off.
You can knock off the same
number of zeroes off of the
divisor as the dividend.
So we knock off one zero here,
one zero there, it becomes 480
divided by 8, and that's
an easier problem.
8 goes into 480, and you say 8
goes into-- it doesn't go into
4, so it goes into
48 six times.
6 times 8 is 48.
You have no remainder.
Bring down this zero.
8 goes into 0 zero times.
0 times 8 is 0.
No remainder.
And we get 60 again, so either
way would have worked.
This way is a little
bit faster.
You might be able to do it in
your head, but no matter which
way you do it, you get 60 as our
answer, and we confirmed
that it really works.